au micro nouveau variant du coc vide
circulent déjà en europe après avoir été
détecté en afrique du sud il a également
été identifié aux pays bas où une
soixantaine de passagers sous
surveillance conséquence plusieurs
liaisons aériennes ont été suspendus
avec l'afrique australe et pretoria dit
se sentir punis et injustement traité
la crise continue aux antilles
françaises malgré l annonce de
l'exécutif de repousser l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants et pompiers au
31 décembre une crise qui a mis en
lumière une situation économique et
sociale très dégradée en martinique et
en guadeloupe pour cette dernière le
ministre d outre-mer sébastien lecornu a
expliqué que le gouvernement était prêt
à parler de l'autonomie de l'île
afghanistan l'aéroport de kaboul
longtemps administrée par les américains
est désormais sous contrôle des talibans
est opérationnel la liste des
destinations aérienne s'allonge
l'activité passagère reprend
progressivement reportage sur place dans
ce jour
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver sur arte france pour une
nouvelle page d'information le nouveau
variant du coc vide s'invite au coeur de
l'actualité au micro ont détecté pour la
première fois en afrique du sud
circulent désormais dans de nombreux
pays en europe l'inquiétude grandit
royaume uni où deux cas ont été
enregistrés boris johnson d'ursidés
mesure d'entrée afin de ralentir la
propagation du variant toute personne
entrant sur le territoire devra passer
un test pcr deux jours après son arrivée
et s'isoler jusqu'au résultat jugé
préoccupant par le ms l'efficacité des
vaccins sur cette forme mutante est
encore à l'étude dans la tente les pays
en insistant de leurs vols vers et en
provenance d'afrique australe à
johannesburg les avis sont partagés sur
la vaccination après l'apparition de ce
nouveau variant écoutez
j'ai entendu parler du nouveau variant
et je suis choqué parce que l'année
dernière il y avait le variant delta est
maintenant celui ci dont ils disent que
même si vous êtes vacciné il se peut que
vous ne soyez pas protégés contre lui
c'est un choix personnel d'être
vaccinées ou non mais pour être plus
prudent je dirais aux gens de se faire
vacciner maintenant parce qu'ils vivent
une période effrayante
les vaccins ne m'ont pas vraiment guéri
depuis mon plus jeune âge j'ai été
vacciné à l'école quand j'étais enfant
et cela m'a rendu malade personnellement
je préfèrerais prendre une pilule plutôt
que de recevoir une injection car les
vaccins me rendent malade c'est ça mon
problème est parmi les pays européens
qui ont fermé leurs frontières à
l'afrique du sud les pays bas dont 61
passagers en provenance de johannesburg
ont été testés positifs au co vidéo à
leur arrivée à amsterdam ils ont été
placés en quarantaine
l'éventuelle
12 microns
les hollandais qui dès demain verront
leurs bars restaurants et commerces non
essentiels fermés à partir de 17h à
l'aéroport d'amsterdam après plusieurs
retards de leurs vols certains touristes
néerlandais se disent soulagés d'être
rentré d'afrique du sud il s'étonne
toutefois de l'absence de protocole
sanitaire à l'arrivée
on était très anxieux parce qu'on ne
savait pas ce qui se passait et parce
qu'on a dû attendre longtemps car notre
vol était retardé
ce qui nous a également effrayé c'est
quand les gens d'air france ont été
presque tous refoulé alors on a tous eu
très peur que la même chose nous arrive
et heureusement ça n'a pas été le cas
on a appris qu'il y avait un nouveau
variant bien sûr et on s'est dit qu'il
serait peut-être impossible de rentrer
ce week end ou lundi alors on a préféré
ne pas attendre de faire face à des
circonstances difficiles et voir ce qui
se passait du coup on a pris nos billets
d'avion hier
on pensait qu'on allait nous donner des
instructions qu'il faut aller faire un
test se confiner cinq jours et puis
faire un autre test mais personne ne
nous a rien dit c'est tellement étrange
parce qu'il faut présenter les résultats
des tests hausse partout partout partout
et puis vous arriver ainsi à sery paul
et personne ne vous donne l'instruction
jean paul stahl infectiologues aussi à
chu de grenoble est isolé le sud de
l'afrique du reste du monde n'est qu'une
réponse temporaire à la propagation du
variant
isoler le sud de l'afrique de reste du
monde sait c'est se donner un petit peu
de temps pour avoir un peu plus
d'informations sur le sur sur ce variant
et de pouvoir en apprécier les les
conséquences mais c'est uniquement se
donner du temps ça ne peut pas être une
solution pérenne
l'alpha isère est en train d'évaluer le
risque de
de d'impact sur la qualité de la
vaccination on n'a pas de résultats qui
puissent nous faire présager quoi que ce
soit ce que ce qui est à peu près
vraisemblable c'est que si jamais si
jamais il y avait un impact sur la
qualité maximale ne sera pas du tout ou
rien c'est à dire ça ne ramènera pas la
situation à 0 et les vaccins qui sont
remarquablement efficace actuellement
pourrait dès jeudi bien ça au
conditionnel pourrait éventuellement
perd un peu d'efficacité mais d'arriver
jusqu'à zéro efficacité ça j'y crois pas
en australie des milliers de personnes
se sont rassemblés à sydney ou encore à
melbourne des manifestations générale
contre les mesures restrictives liés aux
copies de 19 les précisions de cyrielle
bouille
l'australie se soulèvent face à
l'obligation vaccinale des milliers de
personnes ont défilé dans 6 des la
capitale de nouvelle galles du sud
l'état le plus peuplé d'australie cent
cinquante mille personnes selon les
organisateurs
9000 selon la police des manifestants
qui brandissent des drapeaux australiens
et clament à l'unisson leur droit à la
liberté les gens devraient avoir la
liberté de choisir ce qui va dans leur
corps et ne devrait pas être puni pour
avoir dit non
si vous devez donner votre consentement
pour avoir des relations sexuelles
pourquoi ne pouvez-vous pas dire non à
cette feature expérimental
22 ans comme sage femme 31 ans comme
infirmière j'étends a donné tant
l'expérience à partager je veux être
avec les fans qui ont leur bébé est bien
m'occuper d'elle mais un jour on m'a dit
que je ne pouvais pas revenir au travail
et que c'était la fin de ma carrière
un combattant
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour marcher
avec le peuple redonner le pouvoir au
peuple allons-y c'est notre heure nous
allons apporter le changement nous
allons nous opposer au régime maléfique
qui a affecté nos vies il est temps de
se tenir avec nous unissons-nous en
solidarité allons-y
même climat tendu à melbourne pour le
troisième week-end consécutif des
manifestants se sont rassemblés et ont
exprimé leur colère et leur
incompréhension face aux restrictions en
vigueur dans l'état de victoria les
personnes travaillant dans le secteur
médical celui de l'éducation ou encore
dans les transports sont obligés de se
faire vacciner s'ils souhaitent garder
leur emploi les personnes non vaccinées
ne peuvent pas se rendre au restaurant
ou dans les magasins à moins d'acheter
des produits dits essentiels
ils veulent faire de la discrimination
contre les gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés
comme ils disent et je pense que c'est
la chose la plus écoeurante que j'ai
jamais vu dans ce pays j'ai parlé à tant
de familles et de personnes qui
s'inquiètent des effets que ces mandats
pourrait avoir sur les enfants séparés
de la société ils ont été tellement
éprouvé au cours des 18 derniers mois
ils ont manqué l'école ont été enfermés
à la maison je pense que c'est dangereux
ce que fait le gouvernement en ayant des
pouvoirs importants pour séparer les
enfants du reste de la société nous
devons arrêter cela immédiatement
un projet de loi à l'étude est également
dans le viseur des manifestants il
permettrait au gouvernement de l'état de
victoria de prendre de nouvelles
ordonnances en cas de pandémie s'il juge
que cela contribue à protéger la santé
publique un projet qui soulèvent de
grandes inquiétudes du côté du parti
libéral et des groupes de défense des
droits
manifestation cet après midi à pointe à
pitre plusieurs milliers de personnes
défilent dans le calme depuis le chu
bloqués depuis plus d'une semaine
jusqu'à l'un des barrages de lille plus
que jamais la crise continue aux
antilles françaises où l'obligation
vaccinale du personnel soignant et des
pompiers restent source de tension
malgré les annonces de repousser cette
obligation au 31 décembre la colère des
manifestants ne retombe pas marciel
ouvre
tentative d'apaisement peu efficace du
gouvernement aux antilles 'l'annonce
hier de repousser au 31 décembre
l'obligation vaccinale ne satisfait pas
les manifestants toujours remonter soro
veut se rendre sur l'obligation
vaccinale jusque
là on avait choisi tout
reste
à vérifier n'était pas l'année on en a
déjà pris d'autres mouvements et les
fêtes ont été sacrifiés donc ce sera
parce qu'elle fait mais c'est pour la
bonne cause de toute façon pourquoi y
avoir de fait le morane pourra pas être
là s'il n'y a pas une sérénité derrière
et la sérénité l2 tient qu'à la reprise
d'une activité professionnelle
même son de cloche en martinique où la
mobilisation débuté le 22 novembre
perdure des barrages ralentissent
toujours la circulation parfois érigés
par des pompiers également concernées
par l'obligation vaccinale on a mis un
barrage depuis deux jours le barrage
mobile qui permet de laisser entrer tout
ce qui est personnel soignant et qui
n'est au niveau de la zone 10 k now là
en accord avec les dockers de lille nous
position il nous positionnons ici pour
faire réagir le représentant de l'état
non à l'obligation vaccinale est le nom
au passé habité c'est ça ne
passait le 31 décembre les soignants et
pompier non vaccinés seront suspendus de
leurs fonctions la population
martiniquaise comprend les mobilisations
bah oui je comprends
je comprends mais
où ça va aller on va jusqu'où comme ça
parce que je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup
de dégâts humains matériels savoir
humain surtout la nuit tombée la
mobilisation ne s'arrête pas pour autant
rien ne semble perturber les
manifestants si c'est pour se battre se
bat tous nos enfants 3 japon moment que
tu or on ne pensait pas éveillé là on se
réveille et bien nous sommes là en
barrage de poubara et tout le week-end
ah ben on va aller tout le week-end on
va rentrer chez nous ya deux cas on va
te changer pendant retourner les grands
gabarits aujourd'hui la jeunesse de
martinique se réveille elle se réveille
des fois mal elle se rêvait en agissant
des fois pas correctement ou en faisant
des choses qui ne sont pas fans de rock
mais c'est c'est parfois dans la
destruction que nous faisons là la
révolution outre les barrages des
affrontements ont eu lieu avec les
forces de l'ordre la police a de nouveau
été visés par des tirs à balles réelles
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi un
bain q le policier a notamment été
touché à fort de france 100 des cas
humains lors d'une intervention suite au
pillage d'une station-service
150 interpellations ont déjà été
comptabilisés dans les départements
d'outre-mer depuis le début de la
mobilisation
cette crise dans les antilles françaises
n'est donc de l'opposition de
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants a
révélé un véritable mal être au sein de
la population et a mis en lumière une
situation sociale et économique très
dégradé le ministre d outre-mer a pris
la parole hier il se dit prêt à parler
de l'autonomie de la guadeloupe il n'y a
pas de mauvais débat a selon lui
certains élus ont posé la question en
creux de l'autonomie par rapport à son
statut actuel de départements ou régions
d'outre-mer d'après eux la guadeloupe
pourrait mieux se gérer d'elle-même il
faut être moins d'égalité avec
l'hexagone plus de liberté de décision
par les décideurs locaux le gouvernement
est prêt à en parler il n'y a pas de
mauvais débat du moment que ce débat
serve à résoudre les vrais problèmes du
quotidien des guadeloupéens et des
goudes ou p1 du concret moins de paroles
plus d'action une déclaration qui n'est
pas du tout du goût d'une partie de
l'opposition en écoute xavier bertrand
et marine le pen
pour essayer d'acheter les
indépendantistes radicaux le
gouvernement se dit prêt à lâcher la
guadeloupe ce n'est pas ce que les
guadeloupéens attendent ils attendent de
l'état d'être protégés et respectés et
qu'on leur offre des perspectives
d'avenir
la réponse gouvernementale à la crise
aux antilles c'est l'autonomie
les guadeloupéens et les martiniquais ne
veulent pas moins d'état au contraire
ils entendent que l'état se tiennent à
leurs côtés et assume ses
responsabilités et en métropole 300
centres de vaccination s'apprête à
rouvrir alors que l'ombre donné
aujourd'hui le coup d'envoi de la
campagne vaccinale antilles et qu'ovide
pour une troisième dose pour tous les
adultes 3 millions de rendez vous ont
été pris depuis jeudi
19 millions de français sont concernés
au delà du 15 janvier on rappelle le
pass annie terre des 18-64 ans sera
invalidé en cas de non rappelle impasse
annie terre qui fait toujours l'objet de
mobilisation en france à paris
d'ailleurs les manifestants se sont
rassemblés tout à leur place du
trocadéro se rappelle entre autres du
leader des patriotes florian philippot
manifestations également à lyon organisé
par le collectif lyon pour la liberté
des centaines de personnes se sont donné
rendez vous pour dire non à la
généralisation de la troisième dose de
vaccin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quand tout
hrw eux c'est
liberté
liberté et 50 kg et lourds si au
registre des vivres et on continuera à
résister jusqu'au bout mais je suis là
parce que le pass sanitaire c'est une
hérésie c'est antidémocratique
c'est ignoble et puis jusqu'à combien de
doses on va devoir se prendre là bientôt
faudra avoir la perfusion ce sera plus
pratique j'ai 55 ans je fais partie de
la génération où on avait droit de faire
ce qu'on voulait qu'on voulait à qui on
voulait et là je me rends compte que
malheureusement j'ai pu droit de faire
quoi que ce soit avec qui que ce soit ma
famille je peux aller manger au
restaurant avec eux je peux plus aller
voir mon fils qui habite dans le sud
parce que je peux pas prendre le tgv je
peux plus rien faire en fait et pour moi
c'est pas possible tout simplement quoi
et pour en parler nous étions avec
michel fize sociologue éditorialistes rt
france nous avons évoqué avec lui les
mesures prises par le gouvernement qui
rappelle l'avant confinement il ya
quelques mois une solution que michel
fize n'envisage pas
le confinement serait socialement
politiquement et psychologiquement
extrêmement dangereux d'abord
socialement parce que évidemment une
nouvelle fois les liens sociaux les
liens entre les individus serait
brutalement des faits psychologiquement
parce qu'on a vu évidemment toutes les
conséquences sanitaires au plan
psychologique voire psychiatrique
et puis politiquement à quelques mois
évidemment d'une échéance présidentielle
ce n'est certainement pas une mesure qui
serait qui serait populaire moi je crois
qu'elle est tout simplement impensable
je vois pas comment on pourrait dans un
contexte de tension comme on le voit
aujourd'hui comment on pourrait reléguer
né un 7 mesures autoritaires privative
de liberté parce que quand on prive les
libertés ponctuellement bon ça peut
passer ah mais quand la privation
devient un état permanent évidemment on
est dans ce qu'on a pu en d'autres temps
un coup d'état permanent on a donc je
crois qu'encore une fois cette mesure
mais n'est pas pensable dans notre pays
une troisième injection effectué
majoritairement avec le vaccin files
heures bio ntech alors que certains ces
roms ne sont toujours pas homologué en
europe c'est le cas du vaccin à un russe
spoutnik v et certains s'interrogent la
raison est elle vraiment sanitaires
éléments de réponse avec vera goffman
il a fait l'objet de nombreuses études
et de rapports par des experts
internationaux sur son efficacité
elle est aujourd'hui homologué dans pas
moins de 71 p à travers la planète mais
rien n'y fait le vaccin scouts nickelés
toujours affublée de lancement adjectif
controversé dans certains médias
français un nouveau rapport du ministère
de la santé de saint marin constate
pourtant une efficacité du vaccin russe
de 80% de six à huit mois après la
deuxième dose ce qui n'a visiblement pas
emule agence européenne des médicaments
qui selon reuters ne prévoit toujours
pas de l'homologuer cette année estimant
qu'il manquerait encore des documents
avant sa mise sur le marché le taux
alors que l'épidémie repart de plus
belle dans le vieux continent mais reste
une lueur d'espoir puisque
l'organisation mondiale de la santé elle
promet désormais la certification de
spoutnik mais pour le mois de décembre
il est peu probable que le régulateur
européen des médicaments prennent la
décision d'approuver ou non le vaccin
russe contre le coc vide 19 le spoutnik
v avant au moins le 1er trimestre 2011
22 car il manque toujours certaines
données nécessaires pour l'examen du
côté de l'institut gamaleya concepteur
du vaccin on a de plus en plus de mal à
dissimuler son mécontentement alexandre
gainsboug à son directeur pour un
notamment du doigt la mauvaise foi des
bureaucrates dont est victime le vaccin
russe il y a en ce moment une très
grande concurrence autour des flux
financiers dans le monde à la fois entre
les différents fabricants de vaccins et
indirectement entre les pays où ces
sociétés pharmaceutiques au père en même
temps on ne peut pas dire que la
législation européenne soient harmonisés
avec la législation russe il ya un
certain nombre de problèmes qui
apparaissent précisément à cause de
cette incohérence et cela mène à des
retards si un vaccin était reconnue en
fonction des résultats de son
utilisation pratique le processus serait
plus rapide la campagne de vaccination a
montré que spoutnik v parvient
parfaitement à protéger le corps contre
une large gamme de souche de coronavirus
cependant les responsables de l'uem a
est en partie de l' oms ne veulent pas
le voir en russie en attendant on vient
d'enregistrer le vaccin pour les
adolescents de 12 à 18 ans sous le nom
de spoutnik m en outre les autorités
viennent de donner leur feu vert pour
les recherche d'un remède destiné aux
enfants à partir de 2 ans vladimir
poutine lui-même a testé le vaccin sous
sa forme nasale encore en phase
d'élaboration
un poste il est exactement six mois
après la vaccination mais niveau
d'anticorps ont baissé et les
spécialistes m'ont recommandé une
revaccination que j'ai fait il ya
plusieurs jours d'abord je me suis fait
vacciner et le lendemain après une
consultation avec denis ochowicz en fait
c'est lui qui a fait la deuxième partie
de la procédure je parle de ce
médicament sous forme de poudre à
prendre par voie nasale qu'est ce que
c'est
c'était la même seringue mais au lieu
d'une substance liquide il a pris une
poudre m'a demandé de prendre une grande
respiration en comptant jusqu'à 3 alpes
ulvé risée le médicament d'un côté de
l'autre j'ai attendu la 15e minute et
c'était fini
je n'ai ressenti aucune douleur pour
être honnête aucune je suis resté assis
pendant 15 minutes après ces deux
procédures l'injection et la forme
nasale j'ai déjà fait du sport
aujourd'hui
selon une étude de chercheurs argentins
qui ont testé différentes combinaisons
de vaccins les meilleurs résultats sont
obtenus
un tandem composé de vaccins adn virus
et arn par exemple scouts nickelés avec
modern à
l'analyse préliminaire a donné des
résultats positifs tant en matière
d'innocuité qu'en termes
d'immunogénicité dans les schémas
thérapeutiques hétérologue mise en
oeuvre dans le cadre du plan stratégique
de vaccination contre le coronavirus en
argentine de leur côté les pays
européens dont la france depuis ce jeudi
se pressent pour administrer la
troisième dose du vaccin dans un
contexte de flambée épidémique cette
énième retard pour la certification de
spoutnik les amène à se poser la
question suivante les intérêts des
populations sont elles réellement au
coeur des considérations des
fonctionnaires de l'union européenne
en iran la police anti-émeute a été
déployée à ispan la veille la
manifestation d'ampleur comme tous les
vendredis depuis des mois a conduit à
l'arrestation d'au moins 70 personnes
deux ont été blessés mobilisation pour
dénoncer l'assèchement de la rivière
zayan des roude à sec depuis des années
et ce n'est pas seulement le
réchauffement climatique qui en est à
l'origine les habitants reprochent aux
autorités de détourner l'eau de la ville
le point en images avec adrien fonteneau
des embarcations au beau milieu d'un
désert pas vraiment depuis deux
décennies plus une trace d'eau à cet
endroit dans la troisième ville d'iran
la riviera yann darroux d'état sec pour
la population locale
si la sécheresse est une des causes
évidentes l'autre coupable n'est pas
naturel les autorités sont accusés de
détourner l'eau au profit d'autres
provinces
une rivière asséchée et des iraniens
exaspéré ce vendredi quelques 500
manifestants étaient réunis dans le lit
de la rivière pour protester
jusque là pacifique la manifestation a
cette fois tourné aux affrontements
entre forces de police et agriculteurs
de la région disent panne outre le
mobilier urbain détériorer des blessés
sont aussi a dénombré touché dans les
échanges de grenades lacrymogènes et
jets de pierres jeudi pourtant
agriculteurs est autorités avaient
conclu un nouvel accord sur la
distribution de 50 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau dans la région des promesses
et seulement des promesses pour les
iraniens qui attendent de leur président
une solution durable face à
l'assèchement de la rivière car dans un
pays aride comme l'iran la combinaison
du durcissement des sols et des
précipitations plus ou moins violentes
font craindre des inondations toujours
plus dévastatrice
direction l'afghanistan et l'aéroport de
kaboul un lieu stratégique désormais
sous le contrôle des talibans depuis le
retrait du pays des forces étrangères
l'activité reprend progressivement
reportage sur place de notre envoyé
spécial antoine clients
au mois d'août dernier l'aéroport de
kaboul étaient au centre de l'actualité
en effet des centaines de personnes le
prenais littéralement d'assaut afin de
trouver un vol pour s'échapper du pays
qu'en est il maintenant quelle
destination des sert-il c'est ce que
nous allons voir avant de reprendre une
activité normale les autorités ont
d'abord dû sécuriser le territoire de
l'aéroport et réparer ce qui pouvait
l'être juste avant leur départ les
américains ont largement dégradé les
infrastructures de l'aéroport le rendant
inutilisable il a donc fallu un certain
temps aux nouvelles autorités afin de
rendre l'aéroport de nouveau
opérationnel
désormais l'activité passage et reprend
peu à peu des couleurs au gré des
accords politiques principalement avec
des pays voisins
confondre
moitié des vols vers le qatar les
émirats arabes unis destination de dubaï
vers l'iran dans le pakistan et nous
effectuons des vols qui plomb matic vers
la russie le nombre de vols est
différent selon les jours c'est toujours
différent parfois il ya beaucoup de
volants une journée parfois peu leur
général le dieu merci il y en a pour
notre camp et monuments qu'ils ya
tellement de là
l'activité militaire reprend elle aussi
avec la remise en état progressive d'une
partie du matériel retrouvé sur place
derrière moi plusieurs dizaines
d'hélicoptères militaires américains
abandonnés ici par les troupes
américaines juste avant leur départ
alors justement avant leur départ et les
ont rendus inutilisables pour éviter
qu'il ne tombe dans les mains des
talibans mais peine perdue ces mêmes
talibans commence peu à peu à les
remettre en état de marche
un aéroport c'est aussi une activité de
fret et qui dit fred dy douane est donc
une source de devises non négligeable
pour les nouvelles autorités
vous savez on peut comparer les douanes
à un tuyau qui alimente l'état notre
tuyau sur le système étatique tous les
revenus vont à l'état tous nos postes de
douane servent l'état tous les revenus
vont dans le budget de l'état
dans un pays enclavé comme les
l'afghanistan l'aéroport international
de kaboul est l'un des seuls liens avec
le reste du source de devises point
d'arrivée de voyageurs de fret et même
d' aide humanitaire le nouveau pouvoir
en place a compris qu'avoir un aéroport
opérationnel était primordial c'est la
fin de cette édition prochain journal
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
où
il y à ces dérives du classique basé sur
l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre terrain
de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire 1 c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut on pouvait l'avoir dernier
110 80 que sur des phénomènes qui vont
concerner la santé ou l'alimentation et
la crise du coc vide à renforcer cette
nouvelle porte d'entrée dans les dérives
sectaires ou des gourous plutôt parler
de vaccination plutôt parler
d'alimentation plutôt parler de guérison
au lieu d'aller directement sur un
terrain qui sera un terrain religieux ou
mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti vaccin
contre le coc vides certains éléments
qui se rattachent à des mouvements à
tendance sectaire qui historiquement
sont opposés à toute vaccination
[Musique]